hey John yes Chris don't say don't think
it don't say it don't think it don't say
it don't take it don't say it don't
think it don't say it don't think it
don't say it don't think it don't even
watch it
the bye-bye man is a film that we both
saw this is my buddy John Flickinger aka
the flick pick he is checking out movies
with me over the past few days we're
working on collaboration that involves
x-men if you can't tell and that's gonna
be coming up very soon but we decided we
go see this film because obviously it
looks like a upcoming classic thanks for
having me I just wish it was a better
movie we could talk about me too I mean
this is the pinnacle of January releases
of all time for good reasoning this
movie blooms in January where movies go
to die yeah it really does uh this movie
made me wish I was dead
it really did let's talk about the plot
of the bye-bye man cap can you tell the
fine people out there what the bye-bye
man is about yes the bye-bye a man if
you just watch the intro to this video
that is essentially the plot except
along the way there's a whole bunch of
stupid teenagers that can't control
themselves they do unlogical things
throughout the entire movie and it
progresses along and if you say bye-bye
man you you die yeah there's a weird
like haunting spirit man of some kind
with a big red CG dog that looks like
it's from 1997 yeah the the CG in Mortal
Kombat was better than in this movie
Mortal Kombat annihilation in particular
I would agree same caliber filmmaking um
and and what is it with these movies why
is it in every horror film nowadays are
even back to the 1990s there's always a
plot device where you can't say
something or do something yeah in
darkness falls don't go into the
darkness in Andy man in Candyman don't
say Candyman seven times and look into a
mirror you will die it's bullshit it's
all bullshit in the ring don't watch
this old VHS vitriol it's just a bunch
of a bunch of like those old urban
legends yes like don't do this cuz bad
shit will happen you know don't have
premarital sex cuz you'll die from
Michael Myers you know I thought you're
gonna say
that yeah so we have our hapless group
of young people who they get a new house
and they stumble across a old nightstand
that has writing in it don't say it
don't think it don't say it don't think
it and then for whatever reason like on
the underside of that is the words the
by by man carved in there even though
you're not supposed to say it or think
it somebody must have carved that shit
in there yes because you know we
wouldn't have a plot so apparently this
thing you know it exists in your head
you know if you let it manifest itself
in you you it'll kill you my biggest
issue with the by by man is that the
entire concept surrounding the by by man
makes no sense they never once explained
there's all this train imagery what is
this dog thing he has where does this
thing come from what is it how did it
come to be who created it what happened
to it how is it able to touch people and
read their minds how does it jump from
mind to mind what is it the film without
spoiling anything it never goes into
like what it actually is or how it came
to be it's a shallow entity and it was a
simple concept here Chris I think we can
all agree this movie originally was
rated R right and the studio I think
accidentally did that when they were
making the movie accidentally I really
do and what they did is they said no no
we got to get as many teenagers in here
to watch these horror films as we can so
they cut it down to pg-13 we watered it
down as far as script and storytelling
aspects go yeah they throw right in the
garbage they didn't care there's no
backstory
there's no build-up there's no suspense
there's so much like hilarious shit in
this film that made me laugh that like
when when of course whenever like a
horror film whenever like somebody
discovers a weird thing that's happening
there's like a research scene you know
where they go and they look for things
so so this kid he goes and he goes to
search that's the website it's called
search when you can't afford the rights
to Google yeah you go to search it he
just starts type bye bye man hmm that
didn't work um don't say it don't think
it hmm that one worked and then there's
like a library in there that helps it
she's like you know back in the day
there was somewhere she
in this town and I III think some weird
should happen and now weird shit's
happening to you too and then I think we
both love this scene with it with that
person later we'll talk about that just
one second but let's go let's just go
back to that scene that you were talking
about that library this movie takes
place in modern day times right this kid
went to a library to research something
hang on if I want to do that what I do
is I get this thing it's called a
smartphone and I just do it from right
here but he went to a library to do this
for some odd reason and that librarian
what an oddball character forced into a
mediocre script to help carry the story
allows early giving she had too much
information on things that she shouldn't
know about and she gave all this
exposition to carry the story long and
the legend of the by by a man but she
did give us one of the best scenes in
the film
I can't spoil it even though I feel like
we should it's pretty amazing it's it's
great towards the end and yeah it it was
it just it just happened as well as
things were it just happened and the
entire film like the scare factor level
of this movie the way they set up scare
moments and stuff it's all the basic
shit you've seen a billion times they
hear a noise they walk through a hallway
they look around there's nothing there
there's a guy out of focus in the
background there's a weird thing in the
corner you know there's a noise there's
a jump scare I was surprised there was
no animals that jumped out like no
raccoons or birds that was like a plus I
guess well they did give us a very
terribly CGI dog that looked like it was
made out of baloney that's true we did
get that that's true it really was awful
and and I mean there's so many moments
that just don't make sense it feels like
the entire film was shot and they had an
OK concept this this thing that is like
the cause of terrible events they don't
go into explaining how or why or who or
what but the concept is interesting and
then the studio probably just went in
and was like hey we should have a shot
where you're panning in on the wallpaper
and a dog figure just appears and moves
on the wallpaper and turns towards the
audience like when that happened some
guy the screening went oh
and I'm like what movies do you watch
that that shocks you like what what
level of movie watching are you at where
like the wallpaper moving is like the
height of the entertainment well I agree
with what you're saying and the other
thing is as far as that scene goes it's
a it's a five second scene and I could
understand if there was a character in
that hallway and it happened no
everyone's sleeping and it just shows a
shot of wallpaper it transforming into
an animal why would you even do it yeah
why I feel like half the budget to this
movie and it's a special-effects went to
that one scene it's just for the
audience it's it there everyone's just
asleep and here comes the wallpaper yeah
I creepy noise damn hallway it would
have been just as effective in that same
scene apparently the wallpaper is Tim
Allen from home-improvement sorry let's
talk about the acting in this film the
main character is the same actor I
believe his name is Douglas Smith he
from the film Ouija another great horror
film the first Ouija fantastic movie
that I think we both loved
I feel like this movie makes Ouija look
better it makes Ouija tolerable it makes
Ouija look like an attempt at a real
movie it really does you know it's sad
there are two fairly well-known
actresses that just show up in this
movie that I didn't even know and it's
on IMDB it's not a spoiler carrie-anne
moss just randomly appears to not even
help carry the story along just in a
random scene they needed a cop yeah yeah
that's it
no they needed a cop I'm surprised she
actually did the movie me too and in the
moat the biggest one uh was Faye Dunaway
yeah is it a scene just one scene like I
guess she needed to put her
granddaughter through college or
something yes fuck what was that
we're just we'll get you a few hours out
of the nursing home Faye just comes out
my grits but that's the problem with
this movie there are characters in this
movie that are very shoehorn in to the
script
yeah they don't need to be there and
when you have characters that are just
wasted screen time it really bogs down
the movie like the librarian
need to be in the move now Faye whatever
her last name is nice lady I'm sure ya
didn't need to be there and Trinity from
the matrix did not need to be in this
movie no they just needed like they
needed the cop character because at some
point people start dying yeah and you
can't have that in a movie without some
sort of police investigation I guess all
this movie had to do was present an
interesting concept and a couple good
scares and maybe just show it in a
unique way sure
the concept of the bye-bye man is kind
of cool and that's it I like the idea of
the weird this haunting guy who has a
dog who shows up and makes you makes
people do crazy and sane things but they
don't take any time to explain what the
motivation for this this thing is why
did he why is this person doing this to
other people why is this thing what
happened with him why all the train
imagery they showed the Cuyahoga Valley
Scenic Railroad train so much this is by
the way I found out going to the
screening this film was largely shot
like near my house and so I've been on
that train so every time you should they
show the train I'm like there's that
train why does they why do they keep
showing the train what does it have to
do with this story you know maybe a book
will go into it one day I mean the back
story yeah the back story apparently it
is this is based on some book or some
shit I don't know I think it's based on
some true events if that's even
plausible but yes far as the the actual
character of the by by man goes I like
the the character design yeah like you
said if he was flushed out it might have
made him more scary or terrifying and I
believe this play by Doug Jones who also
played Abe in the Hellboy moon okay and
I think he's a really good character
actor yes yeah the movements that's
probably the best part of this movie
yeah but if only they would have made
him scare people that were so annoying
and stupid where you want to see them
doc yes I wanted everyone to die
especially the main character yeah let's
get into this the acting in this movie
is ass it's horrible I feel bad saying
this because like I guess some of the
cast and crew were actually at our
straighting it's not Bissell acting it
well they didn't write the script that's
true they didn't write the script but my
god it's bad like the acting is so
everyone's on this extremely heightened
level of like intensity that is just so
beyond what everyone and and then like
like the whole thing is like their minds
are getting fucked up you know yeah but
then but then
like it's just it doesn't sell that
strange dreamlike terror it just feels
maddening the way it's edited together
and cut together yeah it doesn't feel
like they're desperate it feels like
their own cocaine yeah it really does
leave take classic horror films like
from the 1980s you had teenagers in
Nightmare on Elm Street and they felt
desperate they felt tired they felt like
something was after them and you got a
sense of urgency and they and that's
what I wanted from this movie everyone
this movie's just either idiotic or the
main character felt like he was up high
on Red Bulls yeah it really did he liked
most the time even before all the shit
started happening he had this look that
was just kind of like like squinty eyed
and he turned into Nicolas Cage at the
end of the movie he really did there's
one scene where he's in a car singing
what the fuck was that it was just a
random scene he's just sinner I like
music I like to sing it's like it's it's
a it was like a joke the song was that
vibe I love song from like the 58 or
whatever and they just had that in there
like a joke because the titles the vibe
I man he's in the car like by my love by
by happiness I'm like what the fuck he's
having a dude redbull man is a hell of a
drug that was insanity that was pure
insanity I looked over at you right I
don't know if you saw me you were sit
next time I fell over a roomie I looked
over you like hey but then if that scene
couldn't get any worse you just wait a
few more minutes
and sure enough it does yeah she has is
spoilers yeah guys if you see this movie
don't but if you do and it seems pretty
hilarious it almost felt like they
didn't know when to start and end a
scene especially like the editing room
floor there's one random scene it's a
very nitpicky I am sure a lot of people
might not have even picked up on it but
there's a scene where his roommates like
we go outside and play baseball a drunk
and then it shows a scene of the main
character walking to his room by himself
he's like jocks liked to play baseball
outs alright and it's just like he does
something random and then it leaves the
room there's so many random scenes like
that just they don't even make sense
they don't add up and I just can't
imagine any scriptwriter actually
writing that down and then someone
looking at that gun and then the
directors saying let's record that scene
and put it into the movie
I know there's so many scenes just like
that that are there to set up something
scary for instance when he's in the
library he looks at his phone and it
says 1:40 p.m. I remember and he goes oh
cool I have enough time and then sets
his phone down and then then there's
like a time jump thing where he lose his
time and the bye-bye man makes him sit
there forever or whatever that entire
sequence where he goes oh cool I have
enough time was for us to know that some
weird shits about to happen just like
you said with the baseball thing he's
like oh jocks like to play baseball I'm
gonna go in my room alone and then
there's weird scratches because he's by
himself
this entire film the way the scares are
set up the way the screenplay sets up
these moments it's so shitty it's so
poorly made I feel bad because like this
movie had a kind of interesting concept
I just had no idea what to do with it
the acting is awful his best friend is
terrible also in the film the the guy I
forget his name of the movie his
girlfriend
awful she also looked like she was on
drugs she looked like she was on
suppressant she was that yes the way she
yes yes the way she delivered her line
she's like I don't want to go out there
and do that yeah I mean I get that her
character is supposed to be sick
throughout the whole movie which by the
way apparently the vibe I man can make
people he get a fever it gives you like
some the bye-bye fever i / here's what I
wanted in this movie and this is where
the movie would have been perfect for me
okay if whenever a character dies this
happens no no it's right
[Music]
would've been great if they just played
by by by by n Singh ha ha ha
like just yes just one time what does
give it to me they gave me that bye-bye
love song
how funny would that be if he fucking
turn on the radio and it was like that
bye-bye
I mean my god that was the biggest
missed opportunity of all time I can't
wait till that movie comes out on
blu-ray and we can take that one see dad
if you have seen Oviatt just and if you
have imagine that scene with NSYNC
playing the banker yes it'd be great
it'd be great so I don't know about you
but I'm gonna give the bye-bye man and
eff this movie just feel like a
hodgepodge of other movies but they took
all the worst ideas for those movies and
put it into this movie and let's not
forget the premise of this movie is
based around a nightstand it based on
that and this being a worst movie of
2017 so far for sure for I'm gonna get
by by a man and F as well thanks for
being in this video John definitely
check out the flick pic go to the
channel link in the description below
give him a sub he's worth it she's a
good strong cool man thanks man I make
shape they make good videos guys thank
you so much as always for watching
definitely don't see this film have a
good one if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck my next
[Music]